Turner has Jackson in his sights Giles
comes over hedging their swanigan his in
the lineup slashing in his kareem ice
finish me to figure out right at the
real there 11 to 20 to 50% tonight
whispers hurry [ __ ] set to the line on
the knockdown the set just kind of
hesitated off for that screen say can be
escaped ghost of Newark at the last
second but they help from the weak side
dipped all the way in off of the shooter
to take away the roll Newark is outside
drops in a doozy along with CJ Miles
steps in from family 66 veteran Seth
bounces low the college leads and and
late in it not gorgeous reverse hook
Turner fights Seth fakes drives nice
handoff to the following year instead
like reclassification or something and
obviously
but I haven't been able to sleep ever
since I was gonna drop it Jefferson
wanna came back with another question
huh meanwhile I'm watching Seth come off
the screen put the curry
step off the screen squares all that was
a gorgeous cast off the fingertips of
Seth Curry comes off with the screen the
big lean back a little bit too late
Gillian Jackson jr. and both of those
plays coming after eat made that drive
steel on the wing curry
pull-up three right and start to dig up
then the defense is as well who needs to
when you can get three
here's coming on the way set bouncing
all the buyers back for the whole night
the hammer high real baby George thanks
so much and as we were talking about
earlier this is the first time for
Ashley to the second time that we've
seen it no Lillard
no McCollum on the floor at the same
time loser his first two in the second
half nice read by Seth Curry take that
ring up the edge swings it to Zach
inside of Meyers catch redirects Seth in
the air a three count
Oh sensational play by the Blazers in
transition to take Ali to sick Hilden on
the side of the Blazers that shifting
Blazers by six with possession sitting
outside of deep sea Janeiro
seth Curry younger brother one is deeper
than crater lake on the fly
three defenders in the paint sidesteps
his brother and scars Seth Curry with
another triple play allows Terry Stotts
to get some guys back in the game
al-farouq Aminu will step back in DC -
seth Curry one of the few times Butler
gets past et my teammates have is back
in and seven with the dazzling handle
lasers by three look down of it in its
seal here comes curry off the pit eases
one to the window the ball handler
Bogdanovich doesn't even see Seth and
that's because Seth looks like he's
guarded the strong side shooter and as
soon as Bogdanovich
Turner drives here in the corner to me
that's just really bad defense by means
because of his athleticism set fakes the
three steps to the glass beautiful
willow bark cut up and ham
he knows how to play tune hi chief
himself believe et wants his ball down
the blocks that says I wanna three dude
fix your perfect technique his team
coming off the loss on Sunday to
Brooklyn at home
lost by 17 during the run lighted up a
10 they've won 10 games but the balls
are four and seven cents December the
15th it's a clinic right now Seth
working on Parker steps back sets his
feet and flushes a triple great
technique the success Meyers Leonard
tough shot over traffic on the give
curry on a back tap surging down the
floor transition has the pick swings the
next sets his feet for three this is
another guy that can get hot seth Curry
the steal the behind the back between
the legs couple dribbles fine Nick in
the corner bank
closely defended by Morris he'll retreat
works off a series of screens looked at
the clock step back top bang her up and
in Wow you can't speed them up minute
left here and a quarter Suns on a 7o run
Korea's Jam drives by defenders and
fines of laman for the two-hand smash CJ
handles draws three defenders pumps a
runner up in traffic snow rebound fanned
out and thereby Newark curry sets his
feet for three Oh Seth Perry hammers in
a couple of now after tonight again
Portland's got five days off what is the
last time you've heard of that to the
NBA hurry
set Perry who's the second leading
three-point shooter in the NBA against
+500 teams tonight obviously to finish
this thing out they would become 15 and
16 against +500
hurry from D
have been hurt since last year trying to
find his rhythm it's a process JT as we
were talking before the game back cut
their stuff he shot keV it was a lob
play Dallas knew it they slid under to
take away to lob Jake was patient didn't
take the shot
and then he gets around a scepter very
sure handedly clears the timeline it
they were trying to be quick and get a
good one cab he'll drive Seth takes it
goes to per one is right here today
she'll never get a good one as though to
say don't brush it now to pull one is
done just get a quality shot and some
kind of put the team in a position is
still get Burton
big sternum Iguodala sitting out tend to
run right now by Portland
seth Curry step back
[Applause]
Damon for three
[Applause]
Trent jr. will step on out for the
Blazers places have gone to a solid 9
man rotation until now with the
substitution curry finds Colin screws
into the rim to lay it up and in working
in on down to layman pump fake and then
in midair swings it to Collins skips it
outside to curry number three look it up
although it from the Blazers these boys
are moved in that basketball the
unselfishness is paying off
Zac over the top the third-best comers
Newark itch comes up top trying to send
it back the Dame deflected he makes the
catch good ball movement out of a
double-team curry threads the needle a
three-pointer up a ten-cent korean
much-needed 3 7 5 point swing
potentially look like Cleveland was
going to get a steal and go down but
instead set cashes in all three there's
Seth Curry in the game parted by land
for the target gotta get to work
got the fake look for the contact didn't
get it but got the bucket instead of 9
minutes ago in the first half Green
inside oh he should have paid a bit back
and nobody home
seth Curry can have a little room
service at the other end we set you up
down in a post area three feet from the
basket please take the guy to the hole
wicked started wicked hot start need the
bucket curry off the screen into the
lane the teardrop by Dan he heard you
that's against OKC is like a war
[Applause]
yeah anyways the trails hurry outside
the three got another one seth Curry
with that little dribble adjustment the
loop he takes to the side to the ground
step back
that is on Saturday before foreign mold
for home where the please hurry outside
for three knocks it down seth Curry
he's challenged by laymen and misses it
Jake comes the other way good pass
curry is open at transitions and drilled
it and is knocked down by Harold his
second triple of the night Curry goes to
the line is he going to take away the
middleman ET stops at the top of the key
Lillard off the cancer screen drives a
dick set written by Clark outside and he
scores through the contact Seth Curry
will head to the line better defenses in
the league Lillard gives it up
nice set up during his four four has 11
works the far sideline double leaves it
for Zach Collins for three
dancing around the barrel that finally
falls in Dwalin to again just like the
play diagram sac-cid-ananda me who got a
volley lasers the other way curry
threading his way out of the wind for
fader that one after up top and it hood
rotating to the baseline they swing
curry here to the point he gets some
space and lays in it beautifully that is
a terrific move from a veteran and crab
is out consecutive down here's Lillard
bouncing off to curry for three
man that was a long-range Lamar asking
them to shoot the ball from the outside
but that's what you give up and get easy
to vision to make the initial fast Sordi
Murray leans into Jackson with a nice
move yes because that was good defense
from Jackson see to the middle right
through Jackson's Murray takes the long
board yeah that was another possession
where anis does not over commit to the
ball doesn't give up the passing angle
and says how do we get it to get it
through there what about vision and then
time
[Music]
lasers from three tonight curry knocks
down a triple Blazers doing very well
outside they are easy baskets like that
too and tougher baskets like to step
back three Minnesota in the penalty good
to see the Blazers get to that
free-throw line here's curry for three
Wow that's just for three-pointer of the
night here Bayless in front but the
hands are down so you allow fakes to
just steps back and knocks it down
Mattie had heard of Gomes on a strength
despite the chips with the same team the
Warriors Turner bounces make that chest
pass over to Seth courier got another
terrific look at the cylinder it knocks
down his second triple on the advanced
set beneath the rim laid it in on a
redirection Caruso goes down blue so
does not see ball and man
[Music]
and the Lakers come out of an unscathed
Jones negotiating to the inline Williams
hands in tip free my heartless that's
that's all you can ask everything else
will fall into place behind curry for
three
that's their eight three point that he's
really developed into a good player
comes out to steal they're on an Arab
pass you know where he's at moved is off
the dribble not afraid just great place
hustle energy effort then this is what
he's evolved extreme confidence
[Applause]
Goodyear didn't play much in the
playoffs last year curry left open
[Applause]
shooter inside cancer nice play
Westbrook right into the hands of Kraft
and now Perry the pic behind the back
buckless yes
thumbs up short walk by Millsap Turner
gets it back seth Curry put three yes 14
assists in his third triple double in
his first 10 playoff games again you
know he's feeling it they're trying to
run something to get that call that set
30 the ball again that's okay
chef curry
eleven in the corner Bach coming to an
end at 3:00
here's Lillard gives it up gotta get one
up here is curry
[Applause]
her younger brother of Steph making a
name for himself with the Blazers after
a quick break we'll send it over to EJ
in the gang it's the American Express
halftime report Blazers on tucks eight
footer he's mastered at it just so soft
it hits the rim and dies as you see
curry rise up and knock down the three
we're trying to get on track finds
Turner curry Kelly for three just got it
off in time
and it goes through curry hood fakes
curry tries to three Seth Curry
Damian Lillard fakes tries to draw the
foul Chuck won't go set curry for three
looks it in Seth Curry from downtown
Portland back up by one Steph Curry
against cook Walmart Duke teammates at
curry
Kirsten they want to trap that just like
they're trapping Willard in McCullum and
Seth Curry with a little step back it's
back to 15
[Applause]
seth Curry with a steal Seth Curry with
a three to fit in around great players
speaker said he's turned into a
fantastic player who complements us
exactly what you said is finished what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content